y en directo dábamos hasta caracas
porque hoy el presidente nicolás maduro
recibió en el palacio de miraflores al
embajador colombiano armando benedetti
quien presentó sus credenciales con esta
medida se restablecen oficialmente las
relaciones entre ambos países que
estuvieron congeladas desde 2019 los
detalles con nuestra corresponsal
daniela zambrano daniela muy buenas
noches cuéntenos cómo transcurrió esta
jornada como cómo terminó el encuentro
entre maduro y benedetti
hola que tal el encuentro inicio con un
fuerte apretón de manos y un abrazo
entre nicolás maduro y el nuevo
embajador de colombia en venezuela
maduro local y lo calificó como fraterno
duró cerca de 30 minutos sin embargo la
prensa no tuvo acceso al salón donde se
lleva a cabo un encuentro en todo
momento estuvieron en un salón aparte
viendo la transmisión del canal del
estado sin embargo a través de la red
social 'twitter' armando benedetti dijo
palabras textuales que hablaron sobre la
urgencia de restablecer lazos de amistad
que nunca se debieron romper ya
previamente a su arribo a venezuela el
pasado domingo armando benedetti había
dicho que entre los temas de urgencia a
tratar estaba la reactivación de las
sedes consulares iniciando por tres de
las 16 que se encontraban activas en
venezuela caracas san cristóbal en el
estado táchira y maracaibo en el estado
zulia de esta zona especial que se
pretende crear en la frontera entre
colombia y venezuela para lo cual habría
que hacer una legislación y por supuesto
el tema de la reapertura de la frontera
que como decías estaba cerrada el paso
fronterizo desde hace siete años desde
el año 2015 y la reactivación de las
relaciones diplomáticas que por supuesto
luego que le entregó las credenciales a
nicolás maduro ya están renovadas
daniela se conocen reacciones de la
oposición venezolana
el primero en reaccionar tras el arribo
de nueve de ti a caracas fue el líder
opositor juan guaidó él hablaba a través
de la red social 'twitter' de lo que no
se mencionó por parte del nuevo
embajador de colombia en venezuela
hablaba de los refugiados y de los
migrantes venezolanos que ya suman casi
7 millones y la mayoría se encuentra
precisamente en colombia de los
desplazados en la frontera
colombo-venezolana por los grupos
irregulares de la emergencia humanitaria
que atraviesa el país y de las
elecciones libres que tanto clama la
oposición venezolana también queda
pendiente el tema de la reactivación de
vuelos entre bogotá y caracas este es un
tema que también se tenía previsto que
conversará armando benedetti con nicolás
maduro y sobre un eventual encuentro
entre el presidente gustavo petro y
armando benedetti esther una propuesta
que se que se iba a hablar en esta
reunión que se llevaba a cabo hoy en el
palacio de miraflores